terms of generalities the in general
things lean far more left would you
agree to that but I want to throw back
to this clip from about 5 years ago and
and I'm sure most of my audience will
remember this this is when uh Twitter
CEO Jack dorsy and Twitter head of legal
vayia Gade were on Joe Rogan's show with
Tim p and it was obvious to many of us
that there was massive censorship we
didn't know that the government was
directly involved uh but CEO Jack dorsy
and head of legal so she was in charge
of all of the decision Mak related to
censorship uh she was getting grilled by
Tim Po on Rogan take look one really
important thing that needs to be stated
is that Twitter by definition is a
biased platform in favor of the left
period it's not it's not a question I
understand you might have your own
interpretation but it's very simple
conservatives do not agree with you on
the definition of misgendering if you
have a rule in place that specifically
aderes to the left ideology You by
default are enforcing rules from a
biased perspective well Tim there are a
lot of people on the left who don't
agree with how we're doing our job job
either for sure and those people think
that we don't take enough action on AB
harassment and we let far too much
Behavior go and think but that's a
radical example though I mean what he's
talking about I mean in terms of
generalities that in general things lean
far more left would you agree to that I
don't know what that means but in this
particular case it's how the speech is
being used this is a new Vector of
attack that people have felt that I
don't want to be on this platform
anymore because I'm being harassed and
abused and I need to get the hell out so
of course Tim pool was right and we now
know that vayia and uh what's the Jack
dorsy they are no longer at Twitter Elon
got rid of them very quickly we'll get
to a video of Elon on Rogan last week in
just a sec uh but when you when you
watch that in retrospect it's like man
she was basically an agent of the
government and Jack dorsy by the way who
said even in a in a tweet to me that we
do not shadow shadow ban at Twitter I
was then at Twitter 6 months ago and
they showed me under the hood the entire
system that they have there was designed
to sh Shadow band so I suppose none of
this surprises you in retrospect not at
all I mean look like I said I've been
suing these companies for longer than
anybody I know and I was on a panel one
time way many years ago with the head of
litigation at U at Facebook and he used
almost The Identical words that the J
aade just used I mean they actually
these guys talk to each other this has
been their party line well the left's
not happy with us either okay that's not
an answer to the problem and um you know
what we now know is that censorship
industrial complex is way more vast and
pervasive and there are almost certainly
censorship activities that have yet to
be uncovered and not not to mention I I
I read an alarming report this morning
about sock puppet accounts that our
government is using to spread propaganda
in foreign countries and probably our
own country and you know there are a lot
of things that Elon hasn't had a chance
yet to to deal with so um none of that
surprises me and none of that answers
for the government state and federal
government
pervasive censorship of American
citizens what happened at the federal
level is just one part of it I describe
to you the lawsuit we filed the center
for America Liberty for rogano handling
that was California Secretary of State
doing it and many other state
secretaries of State have done that and
they had their own level of immunity
which makes it difficult to sue them in
federal court over Federal claims so
it's a it's a complicated
situation